foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] em
[Music]
I guess the Herschel Walker story
he's made the right wing
say wait a second
[Music]
no that's I'm just kidding I'm just
kidding the right wing absolutely is
okay with Herschel Walker uh paying for
abortions that's what fascism is
they they want to tell you what to do
with your body
while they get to do whatever the hell
they want with their own
because they think they're Superior from
you
the title of today's show is Matt Walsh
is fascist trash
because that's what they are they're
fascist trash Dana Loesch and [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's right I don't use that word
a lot but here it applies
we're gonna go through the Dana and the
matte Clips today you can guaran damn T
that
but this is just a continuation of how
they want to control you folks this is a
continuation of how they look at you as
humans because they don't look at you
that way
they only look at themselves as Superior
white supremacy it's it's their
superiority
to do whatever the [ __ ] they want with
themselves and their bodies and their
beliefs
and so Superior that they get to tell
you what the [ __ ] you can and can't do
who you can and can't love they gotta
tell you all about your [ __ ]
genitalia what bathroom you can go in
what you can how you can dress who you
can [ __ ] how you can [ __ ] when and where
you can [ __ ]
they want they want to tell you who you
can marry they want to tell you what
religion you can have they want to tell
you what education is what truth is what
they want to be able to [ __ ] skirt
the facts because the facts doesn't suit
them this is more of the same
more of the same
and of course Herschel Walker is still
lying about the fact that he paid for an
abortion of course he did
I'm not sure who this lady is I don't
know who it is I have no idea so there's
so many people that it could be Herschel
Walker so many abortions that you have
[ __ ] paid for so many [ __ ] get
well cards that you have sent that
you're not sure which one it is
he can't [ __ ] remember
he just can't remember
which one this is that he paid for an
abortion
that's what he means
foreign
that a bunch of [ __ ] Christians quote
unquote Christians
would crowd around Herschel Walker or
white Christians white Christian Nazis
would hurt her
would huddle around Herschel Walker and
pray for him
as if as if that is imagery that anyone
would buy into at this point
you really think that your stupid
[ __ ] religion
in your stupid [ __ ] beliefs is gonna
stop women from protecting their own
rights you are a dumb [ __ ]
that's what the clip that's what the
clip about Matt Walsh and getting
teenagers pregnant about
this is [ __ ] gross weird [ __ ] but
Matt Walsh is on his show talking about
getting teenagers pregnant
that's how you trap them in marriages
I'm dead serious
I would not [ __ ] you you are my favorite
turd Matt Walsh says on his show in so
many words the reason why we're having
such a hard time in society is because
we can't get teenage girls pregnant to
trap them in marriages for their entire
lives I'm not [ __ ] you
this listen to me when I tell you listen
please just doubt me on this
they're coming
for your way of life they're coming for
your Independence they're coming for
your freedom they're coming for your
rights
women are first but they won't be the
last
that's what this Kanye West Candace
Owens
Herschel and Christian Walker's [ __ ] is
is to make it's to make black people
feel all warm and cozy
about fascism and it's to make white
people feel all warm and cozy see see
look look we have them here's our token
black person who wants us to take their
rights away from them who thinks that
whites are better than blacks
that that's what they're doing
that's what they're doing
they want to tick back time and it's not
they want to take back time because oh
back back in the 19th in the section
such life was so good
because they want control
they look back at a time when they could
get teenage girls pregnant and trap them
into marriages
they could denigrate and blame their
problems on people of color
and everything everything was great they
had full control and I'm talking about
white dudes
white dudes
and their arm Cairns like Dana losh you
piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] what a piece of
[ __ ] garbage she is a trashy ass [ __ ]
[ __ ] skank she's a skank
and I'm gonna prove it to you I'm gonna
prove that she's a skank
as the word that she uses because it's
all projection it's all projection all
of it I'm well here's what I want to
know
and I'm gonna say this several times a
day you can hear me say this I want Dana
Los to come on my show and tell me how
many [ __ ] abortions she's had
I want to know how many abortions Dana
Loesch has had I want to know how many
abortions Matt Walsh has paid for
I want to know how many dicks Matt Walsh
has handled in his life I want to know
how confused Matt Walsh is about his
genitalia
I want to know how many underage girls
Matt Walsh has had sex with that's what
I want to know
we can do it too folks see how easy it
is see how easy it is
to [ __ ] put them in a corner these
pieces of [ __ ] [ __ ]
people say well you're giving them air
time no sunlight is the best
disinfectant
it's the best disinfectant
it's the absolute 100 best just go ask
Alex Jones
go ask Alex Jones about daylight
about people finding out what real the
real motivations behind your nonsense is
it ain't a quality it ain't Equity it
ain't Christian
it ain't
these pieces of [ __ ] want to control
your life
they want to control you
and they're saying it out loud listen to
them listen to them
listen
and you're going to say Tony well you're
being really harsh harsh language today
towards Dana Loesch really
really
harsh language towards Dana Loesch who
is calling all women who have medical
procedures
that have anything to do with abortion
Services skanks
she said that she is okay with the
elitist rich people paying for and
having abortions
because she doesn't want to pay for
everyone else's it's this stupid [ __ ]
taxpayer pay for abortion [ __ ]
which is not the case
Jesus Christ every time we go through
this we have to [ __ ] bottleneck
[ __ ] women's rights bills because of
the Hyde Amendment which frankly frankly
honestly I am not against Herschel
Walker paying for abortions I am
definitely not against someone like Matt
Walsh paying for abortions I am not
against someone like Dana Walsh paying
or getting abortions for sure
this is not a thing I am against
I'm not against a woman deciding she
wants to die because her belief is that
she should not have an abortion I'm not
against that a woman should have that
right she should have the choice
to not get a medical procedure to save
her life because her religious beliefs
fine whatever that's what you want go
for it but I also believe that women
should have the choice to save their
life
women should have the choice if they get
raped when they're a teenager by some
dude like [ __ ] Matt Walsh
that they're not trapped for their
entire [ __ ] lives by that that
monster
because that's what Matt Walsh is is a
[ __ ] monster
and he's telling us out loud he's
projecting it very very loudly holy [ __ ]
that's why I want to know a lot more
about Matt Walsh
he's saying [ __ ] that people just don't
normally human brains don't normally
come up with this stuff
they just don't
they just normal human brains don't come
up with these ideas
and spit them out of their mouths
they can't stop focusing on children's
genitalia their identities how they view
themselves they can't stop focus on how
they dress what their hair color is they
are [ __ ] obsessed with bathrooms
they are obsessed with your sexuality
they are [ __ ] weirdos
and let me tell you something if you
think this is going to stop at row
if you think
that their desire for fascism is gonna
stop it bro you are out of your [ __ ]
mind
and it ain't just the Talking Heads
these people are scrubbing their
websites so you'll elect them so they
can control you
one prime example is is Blake Masters
he was all in on the Matt Walsh agenda
all in on it on his website and then
they discovered well this row thing us
us telling women that we're gonna take
their rights away boy they listened and
they took us seriously and they're going
to vote against us so we better not do
that
but they're gonna do it
they're going to believe them believe
them when they say they're gonna do
something and they're hell-bent on it
because they are and it has nothing to
do with anything but pure raw power that
is it and control and that's what this
Matt Walsh clip shows you
his obsession his obsession with
children and and genders and all this
[ __ ] weird ass [ __ ] that no one else
is really [ __ ] worried about no one's
worried about someone else's [ __ ]
business
most Americans keep to themselves and
are not worried about someone else's
[ __ ]
the reason why he's obsessed with it
it makes me really think man that you're
projecting
it really makes me think that
that you got you got some skeletons in
your closet buddy
I mean everything else is projection
with you [ __ ] why are you so
obsessed Matt with having sex with
teenage girls and teenage pregnancy you
are obsessed with it
foreign
by the way with the access to
contraception in this country
and the access to actual [ __ ] medical
care for teenagers
pregnancy is at an all-time low he even
says it in the clip
he even admits to the facts
that pregnancy is a medical issue
he didn't say that out loud in those
many words but that's what he's
admitting to
oh when you give women access to Medical
Care we can't control them
it's basically what the [ __ ] he says
especially if you wait if we wait until
they're adults to trap them in marriages
I'm not [ __ ] you
and Matt Walsh isn't running for
anything folks
but he's in control of who is
he controls their narrative he controls
their agenda he wha he is the tail that
Wags The Dog why do you think Ron
DeSantis is so obsessed
with children's genitalia and their
identities and their sexuality I mean
they can't stop they can't stop thinking
about children's sexuality what are you
doing you [ __ ] weirdos
leave the kids alone you [ __ ]
educate them let them be free thinkers
stop [ __ ] trying to [ __ ]
check their genitalia for sports
and see what their menstrual cycle is
for sports what are you doing what are
you doing you people are [ __ ] weird
you're fascist but it's because Matt
Walsh is the tale that wanks the dog
and he gets all these trumped up white
dudes
to wag it with him
to wag people like Ron DeSantis
the [ __ ] we got fake Gabe in the chat
every day wagging the [ __ ] trying to
Wag the Dog
Because he believes that hook line
Seeker the delusion
that somehow somehow we lost our way
because we gave women Independence oh
that's gonna sell really well oh hell
okay wink
have you ever met a woman in your
[ __ ] life
I have a mom
I have cousins who are who are women
I have a wife I have a daughter
have you ever met
a woman
who knows about independence they're not
gonna let you steal it away from them
and us men should stand behind them and
not let these [ __ ] trumped up white
dudes steal it away from them either
because that's what they're trying to do
they're trying to do that for their own
[ __ ] power their own [ __ ] game for
their access to abortion I'm not
[ __ ] you they are trying to get take
away your rights so they are the ones
who have access to abortion
because they want to have abortions they
want to have sex with whoever they want
to have sex with they want to focus on
people's [ __ ] genitalia not [ __ ]
jobs or wages or people not going broke
because of a medical bill or education
they want to focus on people's sexuality
and their [ __ ] their genitalia
because that's what they're obsessed
with
as if other people's genitalia has
anything to do with you
are your job or your or your ability to
pay a medical bill
are your children going to school at
three instead of five are you being able
to afford a college education so you can
make something of yourself in the
economy as if that has anything to do
with this nope not a goddamn thing but
they can't stop focusing on it
and the reason why is because they the
[ __ ] that they say they don't like and
just destroying the country that's the
[ __ ] they want to do themselves
but they don't want anyone to know
so they got to stop you from doing it so
they can do it
it's called fascism
that's what that shit's called
in the 1930s and 1940s in Nazi Germany
Hitler blamed every single [ __ ] ale
that the country had
on Jews
all of it
it was pure unadulterated projection
all of it
and here in this country trumpism is the
same God damn thing
is this is it a small marginalized group
in this country who question their
identity
has something to do
with making sure
that you can afford
to live in a house
making sure that your wages are decent
making sure that you don't go broke
because of a medical bill
making sure that the price of gas and
milk is High
if you want to talk about the economy
and inflation
which OPEC is trending
and I'm not even going to get to that
today because really honestly it doesn't
matter at the end of the day it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter what the [ __ ]
gas prices are
it doesn't [ __ ] matter
do you know why it doesn't matter
you want to know why
you won't be able to buy gas eventually
under these [ __ ] if you give
them power
you won't be able to buy gas there won't
be gasoline or electric cars
them gay cars gazes trending do by the
way I'm not sure why
gaze is trending Jesus [ __ ] Christ
folks we got a disease in this country
it is a [ __ ] disease
we got some carriers here that come and
hate watch this show that can't stop
they can't stop posting on Facebook I
read over on my Q Anon group
the Tony Michaels doesn't know [ __ ]
about [ __ ]
[Music]
good
come here and hate watch
I've had this in my chat too before I've
had this in comments
why does this guy who looks like a right
winger who sounds like a right-winger
who says the language like a right
winger says left-wing things
it's because it's [ __ ] Common Sense
dummies
it's common [ __ ] sense
you don't have to [ __ ] denigrate
people to get ahead of white dude
you don't have to take away rights from
other people to ensure your rights
you do not have to do that and let me be
clear
equality and Equity to the oppressors is
not oppression
there are a lot of people in this
country that want to focus on real
[ __ ] issues real [ __ ] [ __ ]
like making sure that children receive
their education they start school at
three instead of five
speaking education After High School you
don't go [ __ ] broke
because you're trying to seek higher
education to make it in the economy
because wages suck we want decent
[ __ ] wages
this isn't left wing and right-wing [ __ ]
you [ __ ] idiots
they don't want to go broke because of a
medical bill
go out and say what I'm saying the way
I'm saying it to a Trumper just ask them
just [ __ ] ask them do you want your
kids just your kids and grandkids to
start schooling at three instead of five
they're like oh yeah oh yeah you want to
make sure that your kids and your
grandkids and you aren't saddled with
college debt to make any kind of oh hell
yeah I don't wanna I don't want to do
that you want to make sure that you
don't go broke because of a medical bill
well [ __ ] yeah I don't want to go broke
because of medical bill this isn't left
wing right wing [ __ ] folks the reason
why these [ __ ] [ __ ] boxes absolutely
focus on weird ass [ __ ] like bathrooms
and who's got a dick and who doesn't
is because they want to get you all
caught up
in their weird little [ __ ] mind games
about sexuality
because they know the truth they know
the [ __ ] truth Matt Walsh knows Matt
Walsh knows everyone who claims that
they follow him and love him because
he's a bigot and a racist
and a misogynist and a piece of trash is
because they're [ __ ] liberal
he he knows it he knows the people who
follow him are [ __ ] liberals
not self-proclaimed liberals like most
the people who come watch this show
they don't even know they're [ __ ]
liberals they have no [ __ ] clue no
[ __ ] clue
they have no idea what they believe
they have no context of History
they have no context of even definitions
of words
and it's because people like Matt Walsh
Dana Loesch Tucker Carlson Charlie Kirk
Ben Shapiro
Nick Fuentes Marjorie Taylor green Matt
gatz Donald Trump Ron DeSantis have
brainwashed these [ __ ]
brainwashed them
the people who blame who blame the
economy on brown people coming across
the border
are [ __ ] pissed off because they
can't make a decent wage
they're pissed off that they that they
have to [ __ ] seek out some [ __ ] job
to make sure that they don't go broke
because of a medical bill
they're pissed off about that
but their aim in their direction of
whose fault that is is way off
way off way delusional because you got
people like fake Gabe going on Facebook
listen to q and on groups
telling them Absolute nonsense feeding
them up the [ __ ] sandwich and boy do
they love this [ __ ] sandwich when it's
when they can blame it on people who
have a different genitalia or a
different gender
or people who dye their hair blue or
brown people black people
that's the easiest [ __ ] path that's
the easiest [ __ ] path for them
[ __ ] even people like Kanye West
privileged ass [ __ ] like Kanye
West Candace Owens
and Herschel Walker even take that path
[ __ ]
that's not a quality that's not Equity
that's not democracy that's not what
that is that's fascism folks
and only you stand in the way of it
that's what they know that's why they're
so [ __ ] hell-bent on it
because you stand in the way of them
taking full control
to have a white Christian nationalist
fascist State you stand in the way
you
that's why they rail against women
because they know they know one thing's
for damn sure in this country women
[ __ ] vote
they [ __ ] vote baby if they're
registered they [ __ ] vote and if I am
happy about that they are very sad they
are very upset about that
and they're trying to convince you
they're trying to convince you
trying to scare you into not voting
trying to scare you and not engaging in
your democracy trying to scare you and
not using your voice well [ __ ] that [ __ ]
foreign
there's a hell of a lot of us behind you
ladies a [ __ ] hell of a lot of us
engage in your democracy lean into it
[ __ ] these [ __ ]
[ __ ] the Supreme Court
[ __ ] Brett Kavanaugh Amy Coney Barrett
Gorsuch Thomas [ __ ] him [ __ ] em
the only way to do this
is for us to do what democracies do best
dunk fascism in the [ __ ] trash
and I'm not just talking about winning
by small margin folks
we got a pile mountains of votes on top
of these [ __ ]
don't get complacent don't let your
friends your family get complacent well
it seems like Democrats are doing well
who gives a [ __ ]
it's not about doing well anymore it's
not even about winning
it's about sending a [ __ ] message
that no you will not you will not you
will not have a platform of taking away
people's rights
it's not a thing that you're going to do
because if you come from my sister's
rights if you come from my wife's rights
my daughter's rights my mother's rights
my granddaughter's rights you will come
from mine
I've been saying for months and months
they want your children and Matt Walsh
Matt Walsh the tale that Wags the dog at
the daily wire him and Mitch beer are
they're good buddies
maybe that's another question I should
ask Matt Walsh and Ben Shapiro how many
times have you guys been naked together
huh
I don't know
they seem to really focus on these
things
Now's the Time to lean in
Now's the Time to use the hammer of your
ballot to show them what democracy is
what democracy does
we Crush fascism in the 1930s and 1940s
but folks ideas don't die
ideas do not die they'll hide underneath
the rock they'll creep around they'll
poke their heads out every once in a
while but we must
we must play whack-a-mole with this and
we must use the hammer of democracy
to stop this [ __ ] in its tracks
they're coming for you they're coming
for your children I'm not [ __ ] you
they don't give a [ __ ] they don't give a
[ __ ] about what church you go to what
school your children attend
they're ready they're ready to take it
all away you think you're gonna have
your nice little fancy Church [ __ ] no
they're gonna tell you what you can and
can't do in church
you think the white Christian
nationalists who want to control women's
bodies are gonna not control your
religious message in your church you are
a dumb [ __ ]
and you'll live with it for a while
until you disagree with them but you
won't be able to at that point you won't
be able to disagree with them at that
point how they'll kill you
doubt me
you you think you think what's going on
in Iran where they're killing women for
for trying to fight for the [ __ ]
freedom to take off a headdress
these women most of them I I I'm sure
some of them still want to wear
headdresses but they just want to have
the choice the freedom to or to not to
that's all under the guise of the
religion
you stupid bastards you think you think
the [ __ ] regime in in Iran isn't
fascist
you Christians are just like the [ __ ]
fascist Muslims
fascism is fascism is fascism doesn't
matter what religion you use
doesn't matter what mechanism of control
you use you dumb sons of [ __ ] and
they're coming for you you people who
are cheering like fake game who cheers
in the chat
Trump 2024 oh you're a liar Tony
Michaels show me the proof
they're coming for him
he's he's a known dissenter
he loves dissent you think they they're
gonna love the centers no
that's why I welcome Vape Gabe here
I welcome descent I am not scared of
dissent I am not scared of someone
having another stupid opinion
foreign
Liberty is Liberty folks
I think you have the right in this
country to be [ __ ] dumb dumb as [ __ ]
and they are dumber than a bag of
hammers and they have the right to be
but we also have the right
to know that they're dumber than a bag
of hammers
and to know that we shouldn't put these
stupid [ __ ] in charge of
anything
especially when it comes to your rights
so lean into democracy lean in and
here's where I normally do I'm running
over time see what happens is I do the
first day block
at first 30 minutes of the show
and I always think to myself before I go
on I'm like man can I do 30 minutes on
this little subject today you goddamn
right I can
and I usually get the 30 minutes I'm
like man I got 10 more minutes
and today we just have the shitless
Roundup geared up for you because we got
oh boy do we have some tape to play for
you oh [ __ ] we got the Herschel Walker
excuse we got the Matt Walsh tape we got
the Dana Lowe's trash and we're gonna
show to you because you can't look away
these are the that's what they're
telling you out loud they're saying it
out loud what they want for you
for you and your family and I'm talking
to you fake Gabe
most the people in this chat know these
pieces of [ __ ] are Fascist and they're
gonna go vote against them fake Gabe
and you people out there like him I mean
I'd pick on fake game but here's the
thing
is that there's a lot of people in the
chat
that are listening that think the same
way so when I say fake Gabe I mean you
buddy but I mean everyone else like you
that is here listening I want everyone
to come listen to this show I I wish
Dana Dana lotion Matt Walsh would tune
in today
to show them how someone describes their
[ __ ] nonsense
in a real raw way not some kind of
intellectual NPR well uh Matt Walsh see
Matt Walsh has had [ __ ] that [ __ ]
you want real you want Raw
you want a gut punch fascism come here
send your [ __ ] family and your
friends here
tag Matt Walsh as a matter of fact [ __ ]
them
it's my hope that they do listen
because I believe I believe that there
is a movement in this country
and the movement is they are sick and
[ __ ] tired of trumpism they're
[ __ ] sick of it
and it's not just Democrats it's not
just moderates it's not just
Independence it's not just the never
trumpers it is people who voted for
Trump twice who were sick and tired of
hearing this nonsense who are sick and
tired of having to defend this [ __ ]
can you imagine can you just think about
this for a second can you imagine having
to come every single day to this show
on Facebook
and have to [ __ ] comment the entire
[ __ ] show to defend your nonsense
your drivel
because I talk into this microphone can
you [ __ ] imagine and there's all
kinds of them that come here every
[ __ ] day every [ __ ] day they come
here to defend this nonsense
wouldn't be would be so easy for them to
stop you think that isn't you'd think
that there aren't people out there that
are sick and tired of that nonsense that
they have to come and rebut every
[ __ ] every [ __ ] realistic thing
that's Tethered to reality that I say
just so people won't believe it they're
terrified terrified that they'll believe
the [ __ ] I'm saying which as as if it's
[ __ ] hard to believe this [ __ ] it's
not hard to believe the truth
it's not hard to believe [ __ ] common
sense and logic it's not hard to believe
in Liberty
what are you yapping about
pluck your head out of your ass
and realize that the majority of the
people in this country just want simple
things even people who voted for Trump
twice
they want the same they're they're
liberals they just don't know it
they're liberals they just don't know it
trust me trust me on this trust me on
this
I know them
I have them in my [ __ ] family they're
liberals they just don't know it
and that's okay we don't have to have
them know that they're liberals folks
we don't
we just have to terrify the ever-loving
[ __ ] out of him for what they need to be
terrified of
is that the liberty and the freedom that
they talk about the only party that is
interested in taking that [ __ ] away from
them is the one they keep voting for
it's the one they keep cheering for
is the one they worship the deity
the orange Mussolini Jesus
way over time on the a block but I don't
give a [ __ ]
I want to keep ranting today it's hump
day we're halfway through the week
I do have a lot of video to get to I do
have a lot of video to get to and I
think Gabe is um he's like hey man shut
the [ __ ] up let's get on with the [ __ ]
list because I'm just ranting today I
don't give a [ __ ] I'm I am I am
seriously 100 percent absolutely [ __ ]
pissed off about this Matt Walsh and
this Dana Loach clip and the reason why
I'm mad is not by about what they said
it is not surprising that these [ __ ]
bigots
these [ __ ] bigots would say this [ __ ]
these [ __ ] weirdos would say this
[ __ ] that they want to [ __ ] marry and
trap teenage girls and that Dana Loesch
thanks all women who [ __ ] have
abortions are skanks
that's not what pisses me off that's
[ __ ] par for the course for these
pieces of trash
what really pisses me off
is that there's some people out there
still not understanding
how serious they truly are
that they're ready to [ __ ] enact
policy based on these [ __ ] delusional
ideas
that it is okay to trap a teenage girl
with pregnancy for their entire life it
is okay to think that any woman who
receives any abortion Services anywhere
is a skank
they want to put that into policy folks
they want to put it into policy they
want to control what you can and can't
do based on those ideas that are
opposite of Liberty
what they're describing is not Liberty
it's not
and they want to they want to put people
in power people that the dog that they
wag
to enact policy to change your way of
life
it's knocking at the front door
[ __ ] what are you gonna do
about it
what are you gonna do about it that's
the question you need to be asking
yourself hell Texas Paul was on here
yesterday talking about how he brought
it up in a restaurant with the server
Texas Paul said to the server he said
look see that guy over there trumped up
[ __ ] over there you know that
some [ __ ] voting and you know how he's
voting yeah you ain't got to go talk to
him know how that some [ __ ] is voting
that's how clear it is in this country
right now
he's gonna vote and if you vote that
only cancels his vote
you got to get someone else to vote
if you get someone else to vote bam
now you've got an extra vote that's how
you win
that's what I'm talking about leaning in
and engaging in your democracy
you're pissed off about this Matt Walsh
and this Dana Lowe's thing as I am today
well good go out and do something about
it
that's what I'm here to do I'm here to
send you the message so you can listen
so you can enact on it
because the only way we're going to stop
out fascism is democracy folks
that's the difference between us and
Them is they think they can use violence
we know we can use equality and equity
and the people
and Liberty
to deliver that equality and equity
not fascism not authoritarianism not
control
so do your part lean into democracy not
just today but tomorrow and the next day
and every day leading up to November 8th
and as soon as it's over we can take a
day off or two but as soon as it's over
we got to lean in again
we got to keep lean in we can't stop
because they're Relentless and they have
proven it
and I'm going to prove it to you today
so stick around we're going to be right
back with a shitless Roundup I promise
I'm going to stop talking well I'm not
gonna stop talking but we'll we'll we'll
get Gabe Sanchez in here we'll get real
Gabe in here maybe we'll see if him and
fake gate can go at it today everyone
stick around we'll be right back with a
[ __ ] lives around up right after these
messages
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard in blanket will
protect you too hard in blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardon's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show
thanks for sticking around
we got a lot of Clips to get you as we
do every day hey don't shut up you're
just as bad as I am won't shut the [ __ ]
up
of course their aim is a little
different than mine
and that's the point
that is the point of what their aim is
that's what we're talking about right
Gabe Sanchez that is correct oh man boy
am I glad to see you how are you doing
this morning good I overslept this
morning I don't know what happened I
know but that's okay that's okay that
that's why that's why and I went to bed
relatively early I went to bed at
midnight and I woke up like when you
when you my alarm went off and I was
like uh okay I'll go to it and then I
woke up you had your notifications on
silent and it said notify anyway so I
pushed the button a couple times and I
was like hey he's he's still asleep so
if anyone is out there looking at the
thumbnail today like this doesn't look
normal it's because I but I'm doing a
better job at the thumbnails no they're
good they want a better job you can
definitely tell the difference between
the ones that I do and the ones that you
do but I'm doing a better I'm getting
better
yeah we've set up a template so you're
good to go in the event that I'm either
uh sleeping
uh I've been I've got too much uh
streamed water or yeah I had too much
stream water or tacos yesterday was
National Taco day so it was like a whole
thing Taco Tuesday and national day well
I'll tell you what we went we went
yesterday and I had a taco salad and I
know you're against the uh the taco
salads but it was delicious it was
fantastic
and I had to take a taco nap and it was
like a two-hour Taco nap so if anyone
noticed that I was off social media last
night it's because it was Taco Tuesday
and I was taking a nap because of the
the chips and salsa and uh the the taco
salad that I had see the Gabe doesn't
like the because the one that I had last
night wasn't in the bowl game oh okay
okay the bread is I'm not a big fan of
salad but it was like a folded it was
folded so it's like a boat if that makes
sense oh my God no that doesn't make any
sense well you know all I know is that
whenever somebody has a taco like a taco
salad right and it's in a fried
no well I just feel like they're
I just feel like they're kind of flawed
in there just like a hard shell taco the
taco shell bowl is flawed because here's
the here's here's the instructions
yeah yeah but here's the construction of
said taco bowl okay they typically put
the base as the beans right
well some of them put the beans on the
plate and put the bowl on top of it some
put the beans inside the bowl it just
depends most of the places I've seen
have done the beans inside the bowl and
what happens is you get
uh kind of like what the nacho problem
is where people don't know how to stack
the nachos so then you have a bunch of
stuff wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait back at Backup backup
yeah yeah because I know the audience is
definitely interested and they're
probably getting hungry as [ __ ] like I
am right now yeah but the nachos the
stacking and nachos what is the proper
way see I I'm I'm I run away
about uh tacos and burritos from the
burrito connoisseur here what is the
proper way to smack the nachos so the
way that a lot of people make uh nachos
is that they'll just say all right
here's a pile of nachos and then I pile
all of the the goods on top whatever the
[ __ ] on the problem
the problem and the way that you should
do it like if you make it your house you
should put them on a sheet pan
and you should evenly disperse but the
cheese put the you know Peppers put
onions put this but then whatever each
chip has the stuff on that way yeah that
way you're not left with what typically
happens is you buy a plate of nachos and
then all of the goods are on top and
nothing's layered so by the end of it
you either have a soggy chip or you have
chips that are just the chips and you
have no ingredients left so but if you
if you disperse them
evenly and you have a better ratio of
like whatever the goods are that you put
on there right and in the chip
we should make a playlist on our YouTube
channel that's proper proper food
technique specifically designed for taco
Tuesday because it is like it is
literally one of my favorite food days
that I have as is mine you know not to
be a stereotype but I do love I I love I
love street tacos I love street tacos
they're great uh but yeah
those that would be the way that I would
just make what makes street tacos
different than restaurant tacos I mean
is there something specific
out of a truck or a trailer well I mean
sure I mean some some places that are
like
I I could find they're they're okay so
one is the tortilla the size of the
tortilla is a difference right the uh
flour versus Corn typically you'll find
the street tacos as corn tortillas the
little the little guys then there's like
a little bit bigger than there's like
six inch and then you get into like more
of the burrito style because the size of
the tortilla is what defines a taco from
a burrito right yes I know also also how
you wrap it I mean like if it's just
open face then you have a big ass like
taco but if you know oh yeah because
because what you're saying is the size
of the tortilla you're gonna wrap
something see the problem is is that um
and I I always didn't gave a picture of
what I'm most I'm what I'm eating on
Taco Tuesday I'm like is this considered
a taco because I feel like I feel like
I'm being inauthentic when I'm not
eating what would be considered a taco a
Taco on Taco dude even though and also
and also his thing I just want to
specify street tacos doesn't necessarily
mean that you have to have them off the
street like you're not getting from a
vendor
right I like them because they're very
uh
not basic but they're fundamental that's
the way I'll describe them so basically
is you have like whatever your meat is
you could have al pastor you have carne
asada you have boyosado whatever it is
yeah and then chicken and cheese right
that's with you and then well not
all right hold on okay none of that
[ __ ] Taco mix [ __ ] so then you so
let's say that you have let's say you
have al pastor right al pastor is very
basic it's alpes store you've got uh
describe al pastor for the audience uh
okay have you let's see the best way to
describe it with uh
the basic way to describe it is it's
pork now you'll typically see it it's on
like the rotisserie the vertical one
right and there's this is shaving it off
right yeah they're shaving off kind of
like how you would see like a hero right
like they're shaving off a bit like that
and then you've got a pineapple on top
and you're you know La Pina which is the
pineapple and you're slicing it off on
there but it's very basic like you've
got these marinated pork
you know Alpha store it sounds delicious
it is so good some of the I've been to a
ton of like my recent trip last year and
uh last year in October actually uh I
went Mexican and in Mexico City went
around and was basically going to all
this the actual real street tacos the
actual real Street yeah this is like
hole in the wall vendor you're outside
you're like hey let me get that drink
and let me get these tacos whatever and
then you wait and so basically Alpha
store and also other few tacos are very
basic you've got your meat right so
let's say al pastor which is a marinated
pork then you've got uh chopped onions
cilantro and then you've got a couple
slices of pineapple that's it super
simple then you put on the salsa if you
want to
very fundamental but those ingredients
when put together and prepared right
some of the best things you'll ever have
and the same goes for other ones whether
it's carne asada or it's uh chicken or
Pollo uh whatever it might be it's very
basic it's just onions cilantro the meat
the protein you can even have peppers if
you want you know uh chilies is a very
good as well and then you put on the
salsa if you want to put that on but
it's and obviously like you know a
little squirt of lime so good so
fundamental wipe my mic off here I'm
drinking it's so so good listen you know
what we should do either we should have
a playlist or a channel where we just we
just do Taco tuck that's it I mean I
would love to I would love to keep
talking about go around but today's not
Taco Tuesday Tony well you know Wacky
Wednesday man what we're doing what
we're doing is we're living off Gabe's
sleeping in and my taco naps um the
residual from Taco Tuesday to get it
into Wednesday but we got a lot of Clips
to get to so we better get back to the
politics and off the food
um our people are going to go to the
kitchen and turn us off and start
cooking tacos on yeah Taco Wednesday
wait to go way to go get your tacos till
after the show yeah right well let's do
this let's get to the shitless Roundup
where we round up all the Tweety tweets
and the trendy Trends let's start the
countdown
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
of the segment where we round up all the
Tweety tweets and trendy Trends Gabe
let's not waste much time let's talk
about why this gang is a piece of
[ __ ] fascist trash a [ __ ] creep
Have You Have you listened to this piece
of tape from his show yes I have
listened to his uh
justification oh my God his his
reasoning for why a young woman should
get pregnant which is disgusting right
well not only that not only that it's
it's a it's a it's a good thing it's
good for her kind of thing like whoa
this is really weird listen I said this
in the in the first a block I said what
I want to know I would love to have this
[ __ ] piece of trash and Dan losch how
we can get him on the show at the same
time I have a few questions I want to
ask him how many [ __ ] how many [ __ ]
underage girls has this guy had sex with
because this projection stuff is getting
out of hand it's getting out of hand and
then I want to know about Dana losh I
want to know how many abortions she's
had I don't think these questions are
outside the realm of what we need to be
asking these people man because they
really are getting knee-deep in this
stuff oh no I mean they they are
tripling down Matt Walsh makes me think
of a guy who's got a bunch of women
trapped in his basement and he's making
them under uh
uh under under just his command you know
to be his
his Earthen vessel I that is the type of
vibe I get from this [ __ ] creep that
he would be the guy that you if you were
to bust open the basement door Matt
Walsh would be the kind of guy who would
have that type of stuff down there I'm
not saying he does but he gives me the
vibe based on what he says people just
don't come up with this [ __ ] in their
brain Without Really sitting down and
thinking about the [ __ ] most people
aren't sitting around thinking about how
they're gonna [ __ ] trap teenage girls
in marriages I'm not [ __ ] you that
is this that's what they're talking
about here and the only reason why we
have to talk about it and bring it up is
because they are right they are focused
they are completely focused on
children's genitalia children's
sexuality they're rather they have a
certain Identity or think a certain way
or what books you're reading what
pornography they're watching these
people are obsessed with children and
sexuality absolutely [ __ ] obsessed
with it right and they won't stop it's
it's it's craziness it's weird I mean
even if you wanted to say okay fine you
you want to debate the Merit of what's a
a woman and and a man or gender okay you
know if you really want to go to path
fine that's your thing
but when you get into the realm of oh we
should be impregnating younger women
right girls or teenagers it's like dude
that's you're now in the realm of
pedophilia right you have now you're not
talking about a 16 year old girl you're
trying to justify the getting a girl who
is not an adult
to be pregnant not someone who can
actually emotionally cognitively
physically deal with that type of event
traumatic
and during like that type of that type
of experience you want to say
you know what it's actually better they
get pregnant younger because that's how
it used to be we were at our peak in
1957. it was great right it was great
for us I was able to get this woman
right everybody she was in my kitchen
making my sandwiches when I had a wife
at which 16 I got her pregnant she she
lived with me and and was under my
control for for decades and decades I
could go out and I could have sex with
all kinds of women have all kinds of
children that I didn't claim have make
them have abortions I could pay for them
and that woman that teenager that I got
pregnant was still my wife literally
what they're saying because this is in
response to Herschel Walker's story now
the other thing I want to I want to
point out if you look at this picture
this [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] he has some
kind of I don't know I guess it's some
kind of [ __ ] stupid ass
um documentary it's about it's about as
good as the uh how mainly maintaining
their balls Tucker Carlson documentary
his documentary literally is projection
the title of it is projection he says
what is a woman question mark this guy
literally is asking the question what is
a woman and he's projecting with it
because if you listen if you listen to
this tape that I'm about to play he
doesn't know what a woman is he
literally believes that a 15 16 year old
girl is a grown woman that he has the
right to impregnate to trap them for
their entire lives right I'm not
[ __ ] you I mean if you're gonna if
you're gonna ask what is a woman I would
love to ask Matt Walsh what is a man
because clearly this [ __ ] cuck is not
a man does not understand what manhood
is or what masculinity is in the
slightest let's listen
it is not in fact ever since the
beginning of time teenage girls have
been getting pregnant
it used to be more common the peak ever
since I started keeping records of these
things which they only started doing
recently like in the 20th century
um but ever since they started keeping
records in 1957 was the peak for teenage
pregnancy okay so this is what these
[ __ ] always do this is what
they always do they're like oh well in
the history of history of History's
histories like yeah so what they're
they're slavery in history too you dumb
[ __ ] right so what are you
saying what are you saying that if it's
in history then we must and that we must
have it now that we couldn't have been
wrong you are a stupid piece of [ __ ]
trash when you think just because it was
in human history and white men conquered
raped and pillage that it's okay to do
it now that is their thought process why
aren't we allowed to do the things that
our ancestors used to do why aren't we
allowed to do these things right that's
literally their beef here is they're not
allowed to rape and pillage like they're
white ancestors did
100 full stop let's keep listening
1957 not 2009 not today all of them were
supposed to have kids like that's when
we had kids that's my point okay
um so to all of a sudden act like this
phenomenon of girls getting pregnant at
that at a young age that we consider
young 16 or 17. to act like it's a new
thing is ridiculous it's always been
that way
okay
so what he's saying what he is trying to
what he is trying to make a a [ __ ]
fact that is not a fact is that that
pregnancy was a teenage pregnancy was at
his height in 1957. there is a reason
there is a reason why teenage pregnancy
was at its height in 1957 and it has
nothing to do with marriage or teenage
girls liking the F they have all
teenagers love to [ __ ] okay teenagers
they have raging hormones they're horny
they like to [ __ ]
it is a it is it is a problem and there
is a solution it's called sex education
it's called contraception it's called
real life [ __ ] talks with real life
[ __ ] human beings not this nonsense
that somehow somehow it's just because
history has done it forever that teenage
girls should be pregnant that's just how
it should be Gabe yeah it's just how it
should be because history has given us
has given us this this fact so we should
we should just go along with it that's
what we should do
let's keep listening it gets oh it gets
better
uh even biologically and this is me just
stating I'm just right now I'm going to
start by just stating facts so fact
number one it's not a new phenomenon
fact number two in fact it's a
phenomenon that was more common earlier
in history and for you know first six to
ten thousand years of human existence it
was a normal thing okay so in the front
of the clip he admits that there was no
data taken on this step right now he's
saying he's able to distinguish a fax
for six thousand years ago this guy
makes no sense whatsoever and again he's
only placating to White trumped up dudes
who want to control women that's all
he's doing here that's all he's doing I
have I I have I have a way to connect
well if something I'll say it after the
end of this but I'll it's in connection
to Jordan Peterson
you're talking about what Jordan
Peterson has said in the past because
it's the same it's the same yeah yeah
Okay let's listen
uh fact three girls between the ages of
like 17 and 24 is when they're
technically most fertile yeah okay
that's biological that's a fact all
right I'm just stating facts that's all
I'm doing but what happened recently and
this is the the fourth fact recently in
the last 30 years or so we decided that
that's way too young to start a family
why and uh did you hear what they just
said that's way too young to start a
family why why why why would a teenager
why is it too young for a teenage girl
now they're gonna they're gonna tell you
why they're gonna tell you why they want
teenage girls to start families why they
want white men to trap young teenage
girls into marriages they're going to
tell you why just listen just listen
here they go because now worse rates
would probably go up and once you're
that young you can't really make sure no
no no no no no no no no no the girls
were getting married early and marriages
were lasting longer you very rarely hear
about like these these relationships
that go to there uh what is it your
diamond anniversary your 50th
anniversary and all this I it's it's a
dying breed of people out there yeah and
those all were all people that got
married very young that's why that's why
they're still alive yeah that's why you
can have someone in their 70s who's
celebrating their you know uh 55th
wedding anniversary because they got
married when they were teenagers
okay do you want to know why do you want
to know why I keep yelling and screaming
about these [ __ ] idiots being
obsessed with marrying teenagers do you
want it do you want because they're the
ones that are talking about it they're
the ones trying to pass laws they're the
ones trying to set the narrative that it
is okay for a teenage girl to be
pregnant and be married for 50 60 years
for the same [ __ ] monster
that it that's the way it used to be and
that's the way it should be now because
God damn it us white men are being
oppressed and we don't get to oppress
other people and that's not freedom
that's it
it's [ __ ] crazy ass [ __ ] it's crazy
ass [ __ ] let's listen
so what I'm saying is that the problem
is not per se teenage pregnancy it's
unwed pregnancy that's the problem in
society it's only problematic when when
when you are not married and you don't
have the man there to help you take care
of the kids because he's a coward okay
so Matt Walsh you dumb [ __ ] do
you know do you have any idea do you
have any idea the the most certain ways
to prevent unwed pregnancies because
he's he's saying that's the scourge on
society here the way that you actually
prevent and the reason why it has worked
and the ACA has actually delivered us uh
less abortions because there's more
access to what's the word contraception
you dumb [ __ ] you mean
Healthcare yeah right actual Medical
Care medical assistance people who want
to have be educated about sex because
human being things are gonna [ __ ] that
is just what's gonna happen you're not
going to stop this [ __ ] abstinence
thing was the dumbest thing ever that
was the dumbest [ __ ] I've ever heard in
my life it's like telling it's like
telling kids and dare that marijuana is
as bad as heroin what a horrible idea
this is what a horrible idea to lie to
people that hey you're not going to want
to [ __ ] because you're just gonna use
your brain power not to get the [ __ ] out
of here
if you want to talk about facts let's
talk about facts Matt Walsh and the
facts are if you want to stop unwed
pregnancies you stupid [ __ ] then maybe
you should look at I don't know
contraception contraception oh here's
fake Gabe disprove disprove that no no
that's not what I have to do I don't
have to disprove anything because he's
not proving anything you bonehead
this is the one that I do like that I
was following fake Gabe says he's
talking about the past stop the sofa
tree Super PAC
okay one
what the [ __ ] we are not you don't know
what you're talking about dude we don't
have an act blue account yeah we are not
a Super PAC we do not get money from a
Super PAC we have never been paid by a
Super PAC
again we don't have George Soros money
nope your engagement actually in this
video in the comments are the things
that are driving up the video and what
we get paid from that's that's yeah
that's actually how we're growing our
audiences with you buddy Christ it's
like how [ __ ] dumb do you have to be
every single day fake Gabe comes back to
this [ __ ] show and that's fine
because he engages with it and the
algorithm says hey look this
[ __ ] keeps chatting every single
day multiple times with tons of words
that mean relatively nothing in
comparison to what we're talking about
our Facebook views have gone up and up
yeah
we should be yeah thank you thank you
because the dumb [ __ ] [ __ ] that fake
Gabe says in the chat is one hilarious
for all of us to read and look at
because you literally put it out in the
open and two it's because you're driving
up the engagement and the algorithm says
yeah yeah we should keep showing this
video because this guy keeps talking
about it more people keep engaging me
but here's that's why we keep that's all
why we also keep getting people like
fake Gabe because uh Facebook delivers
this show to like audiences so when I
when I actually engage with fake Abe and
I'm doing that Facebook is saying yeah
yeah let's do that let's do that let's
do that let's get so we'll show it to
more people because we want more of
these boneheads to come here and listen
to some [ __ ] actual truth yeah so
anyway I would love for uh fake Gabe to
show that we are ever engaged uh and
paid by a Super PAC uh no one is paying
no Super PAC has come to us and been
like hey you wanna guys you guys want
some money fake Gabe Midas Touch as a
Super Pac and and the Midas touch
Brothers they also own a media company
yeah they have both also do you know
what the Super PAC pays for fake game
the Super PAC when you see the videos
and it says this was paid for by the
Super PAC it's got the little things and
when they make those commercials and
Those ads those are the things paid for
by the Super PAC we don't get Super PAC
money I don't [ __ ] but when he says I
mean hey you know what if we let's do it
I'm I'm all of that but we don't we Tony
Michael's podcast does not have an act
blue we are not a super pick you're not
a super bag do do we know the my zealous
Brothers I know them yeah I know them
well they're they're swell dudes they
love democracy they they love to fight
for democracy which I am all for
and yeah they do have a Super PAC they
also have a media company as well and if
you knew anything about anything
you know what forget all that just come
here every day yeah just come here just
keep doing the thing that you're doing
yeah just keep doing the thing you're
doing but I do want to point out I do
want to point out he says he's talking
about the past okay yeah sure he's
talking about the past as as an example
of why uh we should continue to do this
in the present and why if in the past in
the pre like he's saying like oh well
the reason yeah they're getting young
but how you know the these marriages
were working out and you know why they
why we told them not to get married
young is because they didn't have a
stable life or an income or a man who
wasn't a coward no it's because you're a
[ __ ] teenager you don't have the life
experience to say hey I'm still a kid
why would I be wanting to raise a kid I
don't even have my own household I don't
even have a a man in my life
the man who got me pregnant to actually
support us let because also I believe
Tony talked about it it's earlier today
it's not radical it's not crazy to say
hey we should be paid a higher wage I
think that's what you were talking about
earlier is you were talking about wages
right and and what we want to talk about
right now is that you trying to believe
that women should be forced to have a
baby by a dude who can't support his own
self and has to rely on mommy and
daddy's money because he's still a
[ __ ] teenager or God forbid he's an
incel like Matt Walsh living in his
parents basement who knows whatever but
the idea is that you can't and you
should not force a woman a young woman a
girl a teenager to have a baby
and then raise that child because you
said oh well you know what she's young
she's fertile and the reason it doesn't
work out normally is because she doesn't
have a man in her life so you know what
we can't have teenage boys impregnating
these girls we should have adult men who
have a stable 99 job that's what they're
saying [ __ ] creepy and if you try to
justify and say oh you know what it's
excusable when the young girls get
pregnant because they have a stable
income with a an adult man it's [ __ ]
creepy and it's pedophilia so yeah just
because he's saying oh 1957 it was Peak
when the [ __ ] girls between the ages
of 14 16 were getting pregnant we were
just like producing as many babies as
possible right it's women didn't women
didn't go to school they didn't finish
school they didn't have an education
they weren't independent and we
controlled them full stop for their
entire lives all the way until their 80s
that's what he's saying it's [ __ ]
creepy can I tell you Story game
my grandmother she's dead now
my grandmother was pregnant by my
grandpa my biological Grandpa they were
divorced later on in life
he was in his 20s she was 14 years old
this was a long time ago this was in the
past fake Gabe
she had three children three children
she started when she was 14 years old
you stupid bastard fake game is who I'm
talking about
now and Matt Walsh too I'm talking about
all these [ __ ] white trumped up
[ __ ]
now
my grandpa was a [ __ ] alcoholic he
was a hard worker he did the thing that
that you're supposed to do you get a
teenager pregnant you marry her and you
have a family and you go out and you
work hard he was a bricklayer my grandpa
was a bricklayer for so long and laid so
many bricks he had to have surgery on
his hands because they were formed into
a brick that's how many bricks he laid
but he was an alcoholic he was an
alcoholic now he wasn't a violent
alcoholic but he was still an alcoholic
and destroyed his family over it do you
know the only way that my grandma got
out of that relationship and was able to
move on with her life because she didn't
finish her high school education game
she didn't finish it because she was
[ __ ] pregnant
back in the past they didn't let
pregnant girls go to school just like
that's what Matt Walsh wants you stupid
[ __ ] now
my grandmother went and got her GED and
went to college and got an associate's
degree
and you know what she did she left my
grandpa she [ __ ] left him do you know
why she left him you know how she was
able to leave him because she was able
to go get her GED and get her
associate's degree so that she had a leg
up so she could [ __ ] go support
herself because there was no way that a
woman with three young children a single
woman with three young children no
[ __ ] high school diploma would it be
able to support those children you
people have so much [ __ ] [ __ ] to deal
with
you have so much [ __ ] to deal with that
you have no idea when you say oh he's
just talking about the past he wants to
make sure that my grandmother never had
a chance to get her GED never had a
chance to go to college I I may not be
sitting here today hell I may be just as
brainwashed as fake game if my
grandmother didn't have the opportunity
to get her education to get the [ __ ] out
of that toxic marriage
and nothing against my grandpa he was a
swelled dude he was just an alcoholic
and it took him a lot of years to fight
alcohol
a lot of years for him to get away from
it damn near killed him to get away from
alcoholism
and he was a funny son of a [ __ ] and a
hard worker he was a blue collar guy
he didn't have much of an education he
grew up on a farm
but he knew how to lay [ __ ] bricks
and he worked he worked a second job
Gabe at a goddamn Stockyard
and and a cattle auction that was his
second job because he needed money for
the bar tab a lot of times a lot of
times the bartenders after they closed
they would they would pour him into
their car and take him home
and their family waited they waited
for him to have dinner cold dinner
when they would put him at the table he
would pass out into his [ __ ] dinner
but the only way out of that and it's
not that my grandma didn't love him
right
she was forced into the life that she
had because she was [ __ ] 14.
when she was pregnant and married
and the only way out was her
independence
and that's what the [ __ ] is the
difference fake Gabe between what we're
saying of the past and what is reality
a 14 year old girl that gets pregnant
today who doesn't finish her High School
degree and does not go to college
does not have the opportunity to get out
of that marriage it does not have the
opportunity if that man is a monster let
me tell you something if he's in his 20s
and he's [ __ ] a 14 year old girl that
is most likely a [ __ ] monster yep
alls we want for any girl anywhere any
woman anywhere I don't care if they're
14 18 22 is for them to have the
opportunity that any other [ __ ] white
dude like Matt Walsh has it's called
equity and equality
and it's not oppression on you you
stupid [ __ ] right it's not oppression on
you and that's why this [ __ ] little
clip for Mash Matt Walsh is not only
disgusting and vile and not only
completely decoupled from what actual
reality is because just because he's
stating facts of how [ __ ] was in the
past doesn't mean that it is right
it doesn't mean that it was right in the
past for grown ass men to get teenage
women pregnant and trap them in
marriages
for their entire lives and think it's
okay because ah they were barefoot and
pregnant
they were brood Mares
it's not okay and we know it's not okay
today see that's the thing is we're far
enough away from the 1940s and the 1950s
and then far enough away from the
[ __ ] delusion that Matt Walsh wants
us to believe right that we know the
truth we know what is real and what is
not and when you give women just as much
as Independence Society is better their
children do better their families do
better why in the [ __ ] would you want to
trap a 14 year old girl to be a mom when
she's not even mature enough to make a
decision about abortion Ron DeSantis
right the State of Florida you dumb
[ __ ]
so stop with that [ __ ] and then the
nonsense that you wanna because it
really is Gabe at the end of the day
you're right it's a bunch of old dudes
that want to [ __ ] marry and have sex
with young teenage girls that's just
it's a it's a projection it's projection
it's a it's a fight for for a power that
they feel like they're losing right
because God forbid women have you know
equity and equality in a relationship or
even in society to feel like they belong
and that they are actually respected
right because also God forbid a young
woman sees an example whether she's
white or especially a person of color
sees an example of another woman like
her
that's like oh [ __ ] I could be that
person I could be I could I could be the
little mermaid right like watching those
videos of little girls you know uh of
black little girls watching Ariel now
being played by a black actress holy
[ __ ] the videos were incredible and a
bunch of white people were like oh my
God it's uh this fictitious thing in the
city shouldn't be black it should be
well that's what they're mad about right
they're mad they're mad that those black
girls are empowered yeah that's what
they're pissed off about that's why
they're mad that's why they're mad that
we Society won't let them [ __ ] have
sex with 14 year old girls and track
them in marriages anymore that's why
they're [ __ ] mad right it's because
we are allowing women to have their
independence and their Liberty
right that's what we're doing and it
pisses them off they get so frustrated
about some [ __ ] fake ass Disney
character being black white red hair
black hair brown whatever the [ __ ] it's
a mermaid you stupid [ __ ] it's not a
real thing mermaid it's a mermaid it's a
cartoon you stupid bastard listen if you
are mad that black girls are excited
about seeing a black mermaid
and you're mad about that
you are mad that they are being
empowered yeah that's what you were
pissed off about and that's why we as a
society should not put up with this [ __ ]
because they're mad that black little
black girls are empowered that's even a
talented even a talented black floutist
lizzo plays a [ __ ] Crystal flute and
these mother's flutists and these
[ __ ] get so oh they get so
upset because God forbid a woman with
classically trained talents especially a
big woman especially a big woman Gabe oh
my god [ __ ] they can't have it they
they feel threatened right you know
again you're empowering people who may
have a certain body type and that's just
not what they want because if you
Empower those people you give them power
they just might you know uh might think
that toxic white males are toxic white
males and if Matt Walsh wants to bring
his own because here's the thing these
guys want to pick and choose how science
is used if you look at any anything they
say or anything they read or anything
they post online it's always picking and
choosing based on this study based on
that study based on this analysis they
want to pick and choose how they use the
data as opposed to uh we're going to
collectively use everything and make an
assessment
if somebody like Matt Walsh and Jordan
Peterson and all these other [ __ ]
cuck in-cell [ __ ] Dana Dana
losh Dana Lochte we're gonna go in a
second they wanna they wanna justify the
uh a 14 year old a 16 year old or just a
teenager getting pregnant having a child
and saying why they should nowadays and
what how they how they are able to make
it successful
you also need to then look at it is
an adult brain right an average adult
brain isn't fully developed until
they're 25 sometimes it takes until the
age of 30 right like that's why you're
drawing your 20s you're still trying to
figure [ __ ] out depends on how much
alcohol and how many brain cells you
kill I mean I mean I kill a lot of brain
cells with alcohol when I was younger
that's part of my problem and certainly
like obviously people are more mature
earlier on and what have you but I mean
like you have to recognize that a that a
an adult brain
the whole the whole [ __ ] thing takes
25 to 30 years to develop for you to
fully [ __ ] comprehend the decisions
you make in life and the experiences you
have
so when you try to force someone who is
14 16 Teenage or whatever to have a kid
you're you're you're causing years of
long lasting traumatic
experience on their life that will then
impact their lives
going down the line right because then
that traumatic event was like well I've
stuck in this position I have to do this
like your grandma she at the time she
was like this is all I have this is this
is what's here I've been told you know
like my grandma when it came to my
grandma wanted to work my grandma's like
no you have to stay home I will I mean
like at the time you could you could
actually
raise a family with multiple kids on one
person's salary that's the difference
that we also have today but even so my
grandma's like no you can't work nope
you can't work you stay home and you
take care of the kids and that's [ __ ]
up I will say that right now that is a
[ __ ] up way to look at things where
you do not give a woman as a partnership
you come 50 50 in this [ __ ] you
you agree when you have this Union that
it's 50 50. yeah but she Gabe you're
forgetting you're forgetting this toxic
white male masculinity ball tan and [ __ ]
right they don't see it as a partnership
they're the they're the king of the
castle they're the one in control that's
the whole point uh Gabe fake Gabe says
here the lines being spread today is
horrible fake game you are defending in
the chat you are defending what seems to
be someone who wants to marry and [ __ ]
and get teenage girls impregnated that's
who you're defending in the chat today
not me I'm saying Matt Walsh is a weird
piece of [ __ ] and when he says that we
should impregnate teenage girls to trap
them in marriages for their whole life
I'm saying that's [ __ ] weird and
that's creepy and that's [ __ ] vile
and you're defending it yeah so so if
anything's being spread today it's the
[ __ ] sandwich that you're eating because
you're such in this [ __ ] trap that
you absolutely you absolutely have to
come here every day and say these
comments in defense of your of your
[ __ ] orange ass religion because
that's where this is coming from folks
it's weird this is coming this is coming
this is trumpism Matt Walsh Matt Walsh
has a microphone and people are
listening to him because of trumpism
because they crawl down underneath their
rocks and they think these ideas are now
okay just like they gave it does here
Sophie Gabe you sing I'm spreading lies
today yeah whatever okay fine but you
are defending and this is how you handle
them folks I I think a lot of people
like when we [ __ ] on these idiots also
the main one you're oh just a quick just
a quick grammar Point here guys it's
important to stay in school and actually
continue your education because this is
an example what happens when you think
that you're smart there's a cognitive
distance dissonance and there's a
there's a bit of a dunning-kruger effect
here we have fake Gabe saying the lies
being spread today is horrible lies is a
plural which means that is is are so the
lies being spread today are horrible
anyway continue you know I'm not going
to knock him on that because I would no
I'm gonna [ __ ] knock it I'm Gonna
Knock on your phone
if you're gonna come if someone's gonna
come in and say oh I'm I'm big I'm I'm
the best I'm the smartest you guys are
wrong you guys are spreading lies I'm
gonna call someone out on them you might
want to type decent you might want to
get yourself maybe you spell check or a
grammarly they got a free plug-in on on
Chrome and Safari use that do you think
do you think there's a plug plugin where
you can just type it in and Facebook
tells you whether it's [ __ ] or not I
don't know maybe maybe that he's using
the Q Anon filter too because I know
fake it because he comes here and he
says a bunch of [ __ ] that you see in
like q and on Facebook groups so I know
I know it's copy it's it's copy pasta
man he just copies and pastes it from
some other place and some Forum or some
in-cell white dude is like oh God
according to subsection control sub part
a uh uh Ben Shapiro says that women
should be only with their bare feet in
the kitchen making sandwiches
interesting what what is a wet ass [ __ ]
in the first place and how and how do
you create one what is this whop that
you speak of and I would I would imagine
the reason why Gabe is in the chat being
so upset today is because he loves Matt
Walsh and he loves Benjamin yeah I mean
the daily wire over there is probably
just absolutely uh stuff that he loves
and listens to and believes every single
[ __ ] word that is served up to him
over there so thank you fake for being
in the chat I want to go to
um another scumbag piece of [ __ ] oh God
she is um
I'm sorry no I did not know that she's
gonna make a cameo in the uh Herschel
Walker what was that oh well this is
that's what she's referring to here in
this clip um she's responding uh to the
Herschel Walker Scandal which it's not
really a scandal honestly Gabe I wish I
wish Herschel Walker would have had more
abortions to be quite honest with you I
wish he would have paid for more but I'm
not sure exactly how many he's paid for
and she alludes to that in this in this
little if there's one there's probably
others oh I'm just I mean I'm just gonna
I'm just gonna assume that if there's
again if there's smoke there's fire so
if he's if what Christian said is true
right what he said is true and they are
and and he wasn't at home and he was
[ __ ] a bunch of women around the
country and all this stuff
then the assumption is that he probably
got someone else pregnant right and and
the other women they had the baby
because they probably were like nope I
want the kid or was too late or what
have you
and there's probably other women that he
paid for an abortion for right so like
if there's remember there's three other
kids so there's four kids total they had
that eight children with four different
women
he had an abortion so that's five five
people that he got pregnant and
Christian confirmed this Christian
confirmness and I'm gonna assume that
there are more than five pregnancies
that were there because of Herschel
Walker I mean it's it look we're already
at number five I'm assuming there's
maybe another few or a handful or so
just an assumption based on the based on
the facts
it's all insults and no facts
he can't take this these are insults
these are just yeah I don't know what to
tell you I don't know tell you if you're
if you're not if you're
if you're not prepared to come here and
um being set your comments being set up
on the tee and knock down the park then
you should probably but please don't
leave please don't leave you please come
back you're gonna helping you're helping
our algorithm
so I know it's a lot to uh listen to
Matt Walsh and then this [ __ ] [ __ ]
box all in one day but we have to do
this this is what they want folks folks
when you go out and you're talking to
your family and your friends
your Christian family who believes in
Christ and lives the Bible listen to
what this [ __ ] and I ain't gonna say
it [ __ ] says because this is the
appropriate use of the word here after
you hear how she denigrates all women
besides the women who get paid by
abortions from Christian Republican men
who claim to be Christian literally she
says Christian Republican men can pay
for abortion she does not give a [ __ ]
she doesn't care about save the children
she doesn't care about murdering babies
she only cares about her power to tell
you that you cannot do something listen
to the just the absolute garbage that
comes out of this idiot's mouth so does
this change anything
I I mean do you want my opinion or
you're listening not a damn thing
so here's what she's here's what she's
talking about she's talking about the
Herschel Walker story and she says
it doesn't change a damn thing about her
opinion so all all the stuff that Dana
Loch has ever said about abortions being
murder that it's there there are people
who get abortions or baby killers people
who support abortions who pay for
abortions or baby killers all that stuff
was all [ __ ] everything she ever
said about that is all [ __ ] because
as soon as Herschel Walker a republican
who loves Trump who's endorsed by Trump
who will absolutely 100 percent be a
rubber stamp on any fascism anywhere
that the Republican party wants she is
willing to set all the baby murdering
aside that Herschel Walker has done by
her definition
and she's okay with it now let's
continue to listen I just want to make
sure we have the context correct here
how many times have I said four very
important words
these four words winning
is a virtue
what I'm about to say is in
no means a contradiction
or a compromise of a principle okay so
she's setting it up for her audience to
say hey what I'm about to say is totally
hypo total hypocrisy it's going to go
against everything I've ever said
everything I've ever told you everything
you are supposed to believe about
abortion and about baby killing and baby
murderers and that how abortion clinics
should be burnt to the ground and there
should be no abortion anywhere no
exceptions any woman who gets it should
be jail all that nonsense she's telling
you she is about to contradict it and
the only reason why is because it is
more important that she gets a rubber
stamp on telling you what you can can
and cannot do let's listen
and please keep in mind that I am
concerned about one thing and one thing
only at this point
so I don't care if Herschel Walker paid
to abort endangered baby eagles I want
control of the Senate
okay so again
when you go back to um points of view
and when you go back to how you
construct your political ideology and
here's why Dana losh is a [ __ ]
fascist
is because she's saying that she wants
control of the Senate just like we say
here hey we should really get control of
the Senate now the difference is when we
say we want control of the Senate we
want control of the Senate so we can
Empower all people even people like Dana
Loesch listen I believe that it is the
right of a woman who is pregnant who has
been told by her doctor if we do not do
this certain medical procedure that is
considered an abortion you will die I
believe in her right in this country and
her Liberty to make the choice that she
can die
because of her beliefs okay I believe
that that is that person's choice
I wholeheartedly believe that any woman
anywhere has the has the ability and the
Liberty to take their own life because
of their belief in abortion
Dana Loesch doesn't have any principles
whatsoever when she says when she says
she wants control of the Senate it's
because she wants to control you she
wants the opposite see she wants Rich
Elite people to be able to have
abortions and kill babies and murder
babies as she says
because she's okay with Herschel Walker
doing it especially if Herschel Walker
is willing to go to the Senate and take
away the rights of everyone else
and Gabe she tries to make it about the
money here but when they talk about
money they're talking about absolute
power and control listen to what she
says
if The Daily Beast story is true it is
true you're telling me Walker used his
money to reportedly pay
some skank for an abortion and Warnock
wants to use all of our Monies to pay a
whole bunch of skanks for abortions
so there it is Dana Loesch any woman who
receives any abortion Services anywhere
is a skank which only is again a game
this is projection I told you in the
first half hour that I would prove to
you that Dana losh is a skank and this
is the proof this is the only proof you
need from these people is they actually
accuse someone of something that is so
ridiculous it's because they are that
thing that's what they are it's [ __ ]
gross it's vile but it's it well it's
also the fact that here here's the thing
again when
uh you know fake Gabe wants to say oh uh
don't insult me present the facts we
present the facts and we I mean we're
gonna make fun of you because you say
dumb [ __ ] but absolutely but when it
comes to an actual like this woman right
now is saying oh well if the story is
true which it is we also have Christian
Walker confirming that it's true uh uh
and if it she's like if it's true then
this is some skank so immediately
immediately instead of believing what a
woman has to say the evidence or God
forbid a a child the most public facing
child for the Republican party up until
that night he was on a pedestal for the
Republican Party say oh look we have a
gay black man who supports our
ideologies and what we represent in our
country we will boast and prop him up I
mean I think she also attacks Christian
Walker and calls him a freak in this
thing too which is again
the Republican party doesn't actually
like these people the only reason
they're staying with Herschel Walker is
because he's literally the only choice
they have left with a month to go before
the midterms they can't back out
reintroduce someone new to come in and
take his spot they have to go with
Herschel Walker to get because here's
the thing again this seat that Warnock
has is pivotal to us having our 50 50
split right now and if they take it then
there's the possibility that we don't
gain another seat and we lose that seat
and it becomes a majority for the
Republican party so that's why they're
able to throw out any morals ethics any
side of uh you know all of the hypocrisy
they have they'll just project it on and
say I don't care if we have to kill a an
endangered bald eagle I don't care if
that's what happened I care that I get
that one [ __ ] seat because if we get
that seat like you said then we have
power and if we have power then we can
make the rules and the laws that govern
you and take away your rights and tell
you to do this and what you can learn
what you can read and what you can't
read and what you can do and who you
can't see and all that stuff
and at the end of the day you have this
woman immediately throw out a fellow
woman and call her a skank because she
had an affair or relationship with
Herschel Walker she was pregnant she
said hey I can't do this for whatever
reason because that's her choice and now
immediately this woman is Dana woman
this far right wing radio host decides
that the only way to dismiss to to
dismiss the validity or or or
authenticity of the story is to call her
a skank so by gaslighting and insulting
and denigrating somebody else again a
fellow woman because God forbid you want
to share the same rights with another
person of your gender right well you
want to throw them over the bus he's
really he's really upset about the
insults I don't know where his outrage
is about the insult that Dana losh just
right put on this woman here's the thing
he keeps saying [ __ ] that uh again when
I'm picking on fake game I'm picking on
anyone who has these beliefs because he
is spewing it's like a he's like a
[ __ ] Trump copy machine right yeah
oh yep I'll get the comment and I'll put
it here I'll get the comment I'll put it
here because I'm gonna go I've invited
I've invited fake Gabe on the show I
guarantee fake Gabe will never show up
tomorrow tomorrow or [ __ ] it we'll be at
24 minutes but tomorrow if you want to
come out here here's what here's what
I'll tell you um because fake game's
gonna be really upset because I'm gonna
go
um to this Tucker Carlson and this uh
Hunter Biden laptop and Joe Biden email
thing or a voicemail thing I'm gonna go
to that most people aren't going to
touch that today with a 10 football but
I am I don't give a [ __ ] I'm gonna tell
you what you're supposed to know about
it um but here he says here here's the
here's the Trump copy machine that is
not what she said I'm thinking it you
said she said the anonymous woman is a
skank yeah that's what that's what I
said she said she called the woman who
had an abortion that herself she
literally just said and she said all
other women who have abortions are
skanks that's what she said are you
[ __ ] listening to what we're
listening to maybe the volume in the
lineup I had problems with volume when I
pull a video off Twitter but God damn
man she said if The Daily Beast article
is true right which it is yeah here
again he says you better hope that it's
not a fake story
100 by his laptop Hillary Clinton Pizza
it's a gate Jack about all his his real
stuff that's who is freaking out the
most about the Christian Walker videos
the other day fake Gabe maybe you should
go do your I don't know own research
before you come here and start chatting
and doing the Trump copy machine stuff
maybe we just need to send fate Gabe
like a tutor maybe like a like a like a
podcast tutor and make an app like a oh
yeah a trump tutor app to tutor them on
how to [ __ ] we'll call it dumb [ __ ]
you dumb [ __ ] you yeah yeah dumb [ __ ]
University okay here is hey hey Gabe you
want the you want the proof the evidence
I'm gonna show you the fact from Anna
Herschel Walker's mouth that he has no
clue what woman this is because he sent
out so many get well cards and he's paid
for so many abortions he's not sure
which one it is listen chill it's been a
bit of a tornado over the last 48 hours
I watch you with Sean the other night uh
this according to the Daily Beast you
know this woman even though our identity
is not known do you do you have you
figured out who it is
uh not at all
they gave me he can't figure out who it
is
he can't figure out who it is
I mean
I guess the assumption is here that oh
he absolutely has no clue who this could
be but really honestly I believe her
shall Walker when he says I have no clue
to who this is I've sent out he lost
count you have no idea how many of I can
get well cards I've sent out yeah do you
know how many checks how many checks I
had to say like Jesus Christ
Jimmy Kimmel made a joke about this and
he's like how dumb do you have to be to
send out a check for an abortion that
you want to keep a secret because that's
the truth at the end of the day right
this guy was like hey I paid for this
abortion and I wanted to keep it secret
but I'm so [ __ ] dumb I needed I
needed to have my accountant do my taxes
I think when he paid for this abortion
he had no idea Trump was going to
convince him to run oh yeah no [ __ ]
clue no clue that Trump wasn't convinced
I mean this is all of the Republican
party's fault again we talked about it
yesterday they did not vet this
candidate because they were so desperate
and I talked about this that but like
the Republican party is at a stage where
they are so desperate that they need to
claim and win seats that they will
literally relocate anyone right we're
seeing it with the puppy killer Dr Oz
and and James right JD Vance we're
seeing it with Herschel Walker they
don't care who these people are if
you've got a [ __ ] pulse and you can
regurgitate whatever the [ __ ] the
Republican party has to say you can do
that you're perfect
maybe you should maybe you should run
for Senate in one of these days yeah
that would be great
publicly out there in the open saying
these things yeah I would love to see
that I would love it it's easy to say
behind a keyboard it's pretty hard to
show your face and actually back that
[ __ ] up right actually show your face
out and uh you know like in front of a
camera or something
like we are right now
um
there's another piece of tape I think
it's James Carville I really and he says
something about this um Herschel Walker
thing that uh someone was telling me I
haven't watched this clip let me see if
I can find this car building I think
he's trending even but did you see the
picture or the video of these these
Christians praying oh there's your hands
over yeah oh my God
they don't have any other option they
have to double they have to double down
and back hurt a walker because he's the
only option they can't they can't just
back away and say well there goes our
shot you know it's not like with J.R
Majewski where they're like ah [ __ ] if
we won't fund this guy Hey listen
abortion is what baby murdering to them
is one thing [ __ ] Stolen Valor they
can't there's no getting a DUI and
demoted in the military and they're like
nah we won't back this guy right well
because they well I mean again all of
their all of their morals they'll toss
it out the window
as soon as [ __ ] hits the fan they'll go
nope look in order to get what I need
I'm willing to compromise and not by
compromise I'm willing to totally throw
this [ __ ] out totally throw it out in
the trash and say
yeah I don't need it for this despite
the fact despite the fact that your
whole [ __ ] platform is going into the
midterms has been anti-abortion right
and now that you actually have an
abortion within yourself a woman we're
going to vote against them because
exactly and they're like oh [ __ ] scrub
scrub scrub and it's like dude the
internet is forever we know we have
screenshots I love abortions yeah I'm
encouraging women I mean Blake Nazareth
is basically encouraging people to get
abortions now it's weird it's weird
stuff now here's James garville
on MSNBC
um for those of you who don't know James
garville James Carville is an is a
political strategist from the 1990s he's
the one that was on the Bill Clinton
campaign and James garville just has no
[ __ ] to give absolutely none of them he
probably never has had a [ __ ] to give
but it's also funny because whenever he
goes on he's always got his all right so
he's just like he's just like Jill like
he's in the sense of like he doesn't
dress up for the interview he's like
look I'll put my [ __ ] hat on I put my
like University shirt on or hoodie on
he's like I'm just gonna we're just
gonna talk about this [ __ ] right I the
Raging Cajun James Carville and that is
his that is his nickname the Raging
Cajun and you're gonna see why in this I
haven't actually watched this clip I had
someone tell me about this and I seen a
quote from it I believe but I haven't
watched it but I know it's James garwell
so I know it's good so let's play it
think of Governor Ron desantis's
handling of hurricane Ian so far
well listen to me Ron D Katrina pushed
the fried chicken and the mashed
potatoes in the gravy back the first
thing is you can suspend your toilet
patrols or who's using this bathroom
because none of the toilets are working
in Southwest Florida you can hold back
down the second thing you need to do is
forget about Martha's Vineyard hire a
bunch of buses go go to El Paso to
Matamoras to Laredo to new August to
Mexicali and put a sign up and says we
need workers no questions asked High
wages all right stop all the stunts
you're doing you're going to need
immigrants in a lot of them you can make
drywall people you're gonna need brick
players you're gonna need Carpenters
you're going to need every roofers and
they're not enough roofers in Florida to
deal with this and the third thing you
need to do is change the curriculum in a
textbook and tell young people what the
effect of 87 degree water in the western
Gulf of Mexico has on the State of
Florida I can tell you what it is it's
profound
this guy has no idea of what he's doing
forget the toilets forget the
immigration stunts and forget not
teaching math to kids tell them what the
hell is going on in their lives
and that that's what he needs to do he
doesn't he don't he don't know whether
the wine is water scratches and
scratches watch or wind his rear
I didn't I didn't catch all of that but
holy [ __ ] he absolutely dunks he does
not he does not hold back I mean like
it's
it's uh whenever
whenever Carvel talks man it's always a
[ __ ] show like we said like he
doesn't hold back he doesn't give a [ __ ]
he's always like here he's either God
he's like he's got like you know because
he's from he's Louisiana so he's either
got like some gear on or like some hat
on he's like look
I don't need all this [ __ ] to tell you
what the [ __ ] going on and the fact
that he called him Ron D Katrina
[ __ ] man like right out of the gate
listen to me Ron D Katrina Katrina who
the [ __ ] sticks
I I'm all for that name maybe we should
get that son of a [ __ ] friend and Ron D
Katrina because uh it is going to be
Katrina down there uh Ron DeSantis and
we've been talking about it I thought
this was a Herschel Walker clip uh maybe
you said something about Herschel Walker
but I oh here it is here's the here's
the Herschel Walker lip let's watch this
here's James Carville on herself he he
must he must have made the rounds on all
the topics let's listen speaking of
candidate quality James you've got um
you know I met mad eyes you've got
masteriano you've got uh Herschel Walker
you've got Blake
this can't be a good help
yeah and of course there's I mean how
big of a problem is it for the GOP that
this is this is the field of candidates
they're running in this cycle
you know I've said it before they have a
lot of stupid people that vote in their
primaries I Really they really do I mean
I'm not gonna say that but it's it's
obviously
other stupid people
and they have the the Republicans have
problems they got very low quality
people that vote in their primaries and
they're producing predictably very low
quality candidates it downloaded right
in front
speaking of candidate quality James
you've got oh so there he calls Herschel
Walker the reason why you get Nursery
Walker the stupid candidate because you
have stupid people voting in primaries
we got them here every day commenting
you know who I'm talking we know yeah
yeah yeah yeah but stupid people vote
for stupid people you know stupid does
stupid things that's God damn uh there
was a comment there was a comment I
wanted to bring it up earlier and I'm
glad that uh Cebu brought it up it's if
anyone's seen old school then you'll
know there's a scene at the end of the
movie where where uh Will Ferrell Frank
the Tank has to debate James Carville
and it's an amazing it's an amazing like
90 seconds to two minutes of a clip I
suggest you go look it up on YouTube or
go watch the movie because the movie's
funny itself uh but that moment where
James Carville come like just not a lot
of left field comes in and then and then
Will Ferrell has to debate him on a
topic of I think it was like expansion
and technology and capitalism but
um yeah he comes in and it was a
surprise I was like oh damn and it was
it was a very funny scene
well I'll tell you that
um makes me feel like James Carville has
the like the original [ __ ] him energy
right oh yeah 100 original he's the
original I mean I made it up and it's
yeah I remember they actually made it up
I just took the mantle I I remember uh
uh just watching clips of him in high
school and that same that same [ __ ]
attitude of he was like look man I've
seen this [ __ ] and if we don't call like
it is then no one's gonna do [ __ ] right
and if I don't say that that's right
that's how he got Clinton to win in the
90s right he just got in front and said
this is what we're gonna do this is
We're Not Gonna hide this [ __ ] we're
just gonna do it right out in the open
We're not gonna lie to the Constitution
I got gas like people we're just gonna
tell him the truth no matter how harsh
it is we're just gonna tell the truth
speaking of Lies
and Ron D Katrina this clip here is I
and I I think I posted I said uh
um more cue from Donnie 2.0 because
there's a lot to unpack in this clip
number one Ron DeSantis is back in a
suit already right like you normally
normally during a national disaster it
takes you know two or three weeks for a
governor to get back into a suit but
he's already back in his Trump his Trump
oversized suit because he he felt out of
place with the white boots I think and
he realized that that was a horrible
moment for him I don't know who set that
up for him but it's a horrible I don't
know but the memes I've seen from people
have been
they are beautiful the the green m m
ones and the uh
I've seen [ __ ] and boot day uh yeah put
some boots I've seen Puss in Boots I've
seen [ __ ] and Boots I've seen them
[ __ ] and Boots yeah I've seen uh These
Boots Were Made for Walking I've seen
the Eminem one right it's it's endless
it's so beautiful and again well you
know we're making fun of him because
they they act like oh if you look
feminine and then you're not manly or
some [ __ ]
um you know that's what we're making fun
of there but really honestly the reality
is is the white boots only points out
that he was not doing anything because
he had no muck no mud on those and
really honestly
um you know he can try to play the game
like he's gonna play in this clip for
for his is what would be a national
presidential run in 2024 he's trying to
play that game but Floridians are not
they're gonna see all the way through
that because at the end of the day
people in [ __ ] Alabama people in
Texas and Tennessee
they don't give they they don't have any
say right now about what is going to
happen with this disaster in this
recovery and how they're going to judge
Ron D Katrina here I like that nickname
by the way yeah good ones
it's a good one that's solid D Katrina
here is going is going to pay the price
at The Ballot Box with not the people
that he's pandering to across the
country he's going to pray the price of
the battle box with Floridians and I
almost bet when Floridians regardless of
their political ideology saw him walking
through the street on the pavement
through Saint Augustine with this pair
of [ __ ] boots on to make him look
like he's a hero and not a speck of dirt
on them pissed them the [ __ ] off because
here's the thing when he did start to go
to some of these disaster areas he was
kicking relief out they were pausing
relief in those areas so he got the
actual full press yeah
so I need my photo up like that's right
that shut down the entire relief effort
not helped with it he gave he didn't
even throw paper towels he was shutting
down the paper towel throwing so he
could have his own photo op that's how
disgusting he is his moment of telling
people to move aside so I can get a
photo op is the same energy that Trump
did with the protesters by tear gassing
them so he could go get a photo op with
an upside down Bible outside of a church
yeah yeah same [ __ ] energy that I get
from this oh we're gonna stop you from
doing your job so we can get a photo op
with me and my my brand new white boots
I got from amazon.com
and I'm gonna go walk around and this is
definitely not gonna backfire on me in
any one of them Amazon I don't know I
have to think that he probably or he has
where do you get a pair of white rubber
boots I don't know that's what I'm
saying like I feel like you go to Amazon
and that's the best place to go other
than like a boot Outlet somewhere but
yeah but a Boot Outlet a like a like a a
[ __ ] a hunting store or farm supply
store they're not gonna have a white a
pair of white rubber boots do you think
he did do you think he did like a little
like uh like a fashion walk like he was
like all right how did these I have no
idea these these good complexion like
does it does it does it make me look
thin well he did he was kind of doing
that with his with his mer his campaign
merch he had on people reporting on that
but here's a clip of him
answering questions about why he's the
victim because obviously Ron DeSantis is
the victim here not the people of
Florida he is the victim Gabe uh always
with these Flex playing victim not the
actual people who are victims uh because
of this storm and again no one can help
that this storm happened to Florida not
Trump supporters not bidens of borders
not people who have no idea about
politics people who vote people don't
vote none of that matters about this
storm none of it and what he's talking
about here is describing the Tampa area
because the original path of the storm
that the meteorologists were predicting
before it turned was going to the worst
was going to be predictable predicting
Tampa was going to take part of it so
obviously the media
was trying to talk about Tampa because
that's what the models were saying at
the time before the the storm turned and
the reason why we do all this modeling
and spend all this money
um to to track weather is because it's
deadly
that's why it's [ __ ] deadly because
property can be replaced right the
federal government can come in FEMA can
use money we can use resources and over
time you can build back property get
back property you can't get back life if
you you pro-lifers out there it is the
thing you can't get back so what all the
energy behind um especially when you're
talking about these deadly storms in
areas like Florida the main reason why
you model and the main reason why
they're trying to [ __ ] tell where the
son of a [ __ ] is gonna go is to save
lives and Rhonda Santos here is playing
Victim Because meteorologists were
building models and the media was
reporting those models to save lives
he's blaming it his recovery he's
blaming how he's handling on them this
is really [ __ ] gross and he does the
he does the the the Don Donald Trump
hand signs here you mean the accordion
right he does the the accordion
and he has the he has the oversized
Donald Trump suit on here let's let's
launch well look I mean I think I think
part of it quite frankly you know you
have National regime media that they
wanted to see Tampa because they thought
that that'd be worse for Florida that's
how these people think I mean they're
they're that they don't care about the
people of this state they don't care
about the people this community they
want to use storms and destruction from
storms as a way to advance their agenda
and they don't care what destruction's
in their wake they don't care about the
lives here if they can use it to pursue
their political agenda they will do it
and so I think there was a lot of build
up about that
he is really I I almost bet he has time
blocked out in his day to stand in front
of the mirror and practice the accordion
probably also this idea of the regime
media what the what the [ __ ] okay regime
media here's like God for God forbid we
just you know shine a light on the
people who need help right right the
services that are going out to help
people talk about the Weather Channel
he's talking about the [ __ ] Weather
Channel folks listen the reason why we
have a National Weather Service the
reason why is because the federal
government during a national weather
event like this we give our money to
make sure our socialists pork money to
those areas willingly to rebuild those
economies to rebuild those communities
that is what we do so what we do is we
set up a National Weather Service to
make sure that we can save lives in that
Community because we know we can we know
we can throw money in and fix the
property problem right we know we can do
that we can rebuild buildings we're
roads houses schools churches we can do
all that money money is a funny thing in
capitalism where you can fix physical
things money however does not bring back
life but what money can do is build a
warning system a national
a national regime a National Weather
Service to predict what storms are going
to do that way they can hand down that
information to National channels like
The Weather Channel they can hand it to
networks like ABC NBC CBS they can hand
it down to your local stations so that
they have warnings you know what if even
there is federal dollars that go to the
State of Florida so that the governor
and I'm not I can't recall who that is
at this point actually has the ability
to send out a warning before these
storms hit these areas to make sure
these people can evacuate in a timely
manner so they save lives he did not use
that in Fort Myers and here he is here
he is because the meteorologists the
models the models got it wrong about
Tampa here he is blaming blaming someone
else on his on his [ __ ] up
for Fort Myers because Tampa was what
was in the news well it was in the news
because that was what the model said and
they were trying to warn people in Tampa
yeah stupid [ __ ] you would think that
maybe the people who are in those areas
that are at risk would want to see oh
[ __ ] my area is at risk and I should go
now not everyone was able to get the one
how much do you know about hurricanes
how much do you know about hurricanes uh
I mean I only know from what I've seen
which is wait wait wait are you telling
me the only way that you know the path
of a hurricane is a is for a really a
bunch of real a good people who know
exactly what the [ __ ] happens and make
models based on the historic data of
hurricanes are you telling me that's the
only way you know about them
that can't be I bet there's a q a on
Facebook group somewhere that will tell
you when and where a q Anon uh hurricane
will hit I almost bet like and you don't
need you don't need the National Weather
Service or the national media regime to
tell you what to do
when it comes to a storm and protecting
people I mean if it's if you're talking
about you know a a hurricane drop is
that what you call a cue here here Q
hurricane drop right that's what it'd be
the what the what oh why I'm saying like
was that that would be like a hurricane
drop actually I guess like yeah when you
have all the [ __ ] cue drops coming at
once okay all right just make it really
really bleed your brain um here he is
again here he is the Trump copy machine
fake Gabe says so how they cut it out to
keep you all ignorant this is him oh
this is okay fake Gabe is really upset
about how the clip was made the clip
he's upset that either the clip was the
length that we played or we didn't
played the full clear context I mean you
weren't playing the full context Tony
every time we play the full clip it
doesn't help right because it doesn't
help yourself
and tomorrow we'll play it and it'll
really make you look stupid but I don't
you know I don't want to do that too
much no I actually I do I do okay so
um
again
I said for days and days and days that
Ron D Katrina
I love that [ __ ] nickname thank you
James James Carville you're the greatest
Ron D Katrina was going to [ __ ] up this
up and the reason why I could say that
with so much confidence is because I
have seen Ron DeSantis [ __ ] everything
else up we watched him [ __ ] up a
pandemic he killed hundreds of thousands
of Floridians because he's a [ __ ] yeah
I don't need any more evidence than his
[ __ ] fascist arrogance to know that
he was totally gonna screw up not just
the warning of the storm but the
recovery of the storm and believe you me
fake Gabe we're gonna be here probably
18 to 24 months from now talking about
how his wife and him are under
investigation for stealing federal funds
through some charity that he has made
and how they are circumventing FEMA to
get money to organizations that either
back them or give them money trust me we
are going to be there buddy it is going
to happen and yes I'll stop podcasting
if I'm wrong because I'm not wrong I
know you can you don't need to go very
far to know who these people are this is
what is going to happen that's why he's
standing there acting like the National
Weather Service is some kind of regime
to get him and he's the victim you are a
[ __ ] bonehead the national service
the national service the National
Weather Service is designed to save
lives and we are we as a country are
willing to spend a shitload a shitload
of money and a shitload of resources on
saving lives it's the Pro-Line thing to
do it really is really is you force you
fourth burst forced birthers need to
stop saying bro life because you're not
gay we're just completely out of time I
wish I could go on and on and on today
has been I've been fired up today I'm
ready to go we didn't get to much
because we had a few really dumb
[ __ ] that we had to get to but
you know we run on your support here on
the Tony Michaels podcast so don't
forget we got a Griff too baby I I don't
know well I mean we gotta get we gotta
get it I mean look we're not getting all
that money from the Super PAC so we need
to ask for people to make a donation
yeah we know we don't have we don't have
an act blue account and if anyone would
like to watch the other clips of
Herschel Walker on Fox news that we
played earlier you can go and see how
Herschel Walker then calls his far right
commentating Son part of the left okay
wait a second I miss this are you
telling me that Herschel Walker called
Christian Walker a leftist
yep wow well let's let's let's make sure
to play that tomorrow let's make sure to
play that tomorrow and let's give some
context to the audience too because I
know I know you have plenty of evidence
but you know what I think there's
probably uh what was that coming isn't
it there is a what was that I am I'm
almost done right in there is that guy
in there uh every [ __ ] day there's
something new so I feel like today I'm
gonna cut it off because I feel like
enough has been said Herschel Walker
keeps burying himself Herschel Walker
should have cut it off like a long time
ago we should have just pulled out just
you know uh just cut it off but this
latest thing will tie into because I
talk about Christian Walker and I talk
about my own [ __ ] with him and I say
Obviously you know I can't comment on
the trauma that he's experienced and
that is a very bad thing that people
live through that type of obviously he
mentioned it right he outright said that
he has n't but at that same time doesn't
excuse certain things and I bring some
of those things up but I also bring it
into the larger conversation which is
Herschel Walker the Republican party
this crazy cult religious movement
they're now behind him for it's all
[ __ ] tied together because they're
desperate and they can't they can't not
support him now
I I think I think I can't wait until the
what was that tomorrow so everyone stay
tuned tomorrow it's super important go
follow us on Twitter at Tony Michaels
pod you will find the post there as soon
as that link hits follow us at Tony
Michaels follow game changes that I am
Gabe Sanchez and me and I I at the Tony
Michaels there's so many [ __ ] handles
man now also follow us and subscribe uh
to YouTube download every single episode
on Apple Spotify Google and fake a make
your way over to our Facebook page
um I never want to lose you on Facebook
so make sure you're following me buddy
at the Tony Michaels and everyone else
go that's on Facebook that has still has
a Facebook account go follow at the Tony
Michaels on Facebook until tomorrow same
time same place we'll crush them
tomorrow too folks we ain't gonna stop
we're gonna stop lean into democracy do
it Surfside [ __ ] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn head ass Beacon